welcome to this video playing
international master koblenz coat blends
from italy not sure this guy is let's
check da needed deville me urs is hard
to pronounce GM from Italy he didn't
update his profile information here to
reflect that he's a grandmaster quite a
strong warning i'm not mistaken really
far far above 2500 and regular
tournament just check ok played the
zurich defense to the classical nims oh
Bishop g5 yeah thank you Black is going
for oh it's taking that's that's unusual
normally Bishop h4s play this is a bit
more ambitious so here I really don't
expect to have any any problems ok
allowing many exchanges here f3 ok yeah
maybe rookie form may be looking for was
what he was worried about possible ok
well I can just I can just turn double
on the on the file here don't have any
problems at all
okay yeah still not easy to UM to do
anything active like to feel
maybe I can gain some space here kingi
seven young that's not not really much
going on yeah maybe I should have played
this a bit differently but okay I mean
just in terms of trying something I
don't think I'm in any any sort of
trouble him mmm charge especially 60 and
root d8d 5ed Bishop takes rook g8 is
just a self pin and you know but k this
should be completely completely alright
for for black
you know each for ya probably just just
come with the king
yeah it's um it's not clear what else
Bishop different you can play a form a 4
b 5 that's a possible plan hmm well now
I may be threatening to take actually
not sure maybe you need to to capture
now himself on g5 I mean I think that
position is still really balanced he has
this isolated deep one but it's not a
real bad weakness at the moment check
now that's that it didn't expect
hmm
so there's some more some way forward
probably not it's just nothing nothing
happening I expect Roxy five if it's not
going well see five honey it's still a
draw but at least then I have some idea
after taking on before giving me giving
him a weakness on before yeah I allow us
He allows it but it's probably not not
an issue not a big one okay yeah this I
didn't didn't really think of so it's
not a problem but I didn't identically
didn't really see the shaft before check
yeah well do we have really a far
reduced material by now and this makes
the draw far more likely very little
poem and I will wait to play see 5222 to
clarify the structure even more should i
do that now we have the pronet that's
right choice defy the small risky for
him than for me
yeah I can I can just I can just sit
what's it annoyed check yeah with the
pawns being on one side it's a very
difficult to make any sort of progress
I'm going back to the seventh because of
a possible would be seven and g6 check
check yeah and that's dead now check
blood our third game that's nice of him
that she doesn't play this on for ages
because it's really completely dead I'm
controlling the vital squares in front
of the porn so I can easily set up the
the sixth ranked defense little offense
so putting the the king I'm not quite
sure here I can do put the King to
another eight the easiest and the rook
on the six just covering the
sixth-ranked addresses of a dead draw ah
Campbell this was very solid but not not
really much going on I thought I could
maybe do a little something but it's a
it's really it's really nothing going on
i mean i have no problems at all but i
cannot really do much g5 was maybe a bit
over-ambitious and it's not hurting it's
not not a big big thing but it's not
it's not doing anything at all I think
really this was game
always was chang in the drawing range
jump off check check check my might be
65 it wasn't really strictly necessary
but this is just some just to draw this
position alright thanks for watching